okay people we've hit a crisis anime
sales have been going down and I think
we can all agree we're running out of
original ideas for anime but if we all
put our minds to it I'm sure we can come
up with some what is it sunrise what if
we make a new Gundam oh for God's sakes
we've been over this sunrise you can't
use Gundam to solve everything
what about robots for giant robots what
if we made a big machine looked like
humans but humans can actually pilot it
that's still just giant robot oh okay
you know what no more giant robots are
we clear on that everyone no more giant
robots does anyone else have any
different ideas I don't even see what
the problem is I mean if we just keep
making show something's gonna be good
eventually am i right people yeah
does anyone short on shows I got plenty
to spare here's one for you another for
you I think you're sucking everything
you do is trash don't be like that
Ghibli here have a shell I don't want
your goddamn show you think it's wifey
looks like a piece of [ __ ] it's worth
calling anime come on Ghibli don't be an
[ __ ]
not everything we've made is bad Hey
please don't take eight years to finish
a goddamn movie all right now you're
just being a dick
I'm sorry
how many Oscars have you all one how
about you keep on sucking Miyazaki's
retire dick Ghibli how about you come
back to me when you've made a critical
acclaim bill fight [ __ ] you all
I quit should someone go get him he'll
be back probably if only we could all
have your outlook on life Kyo aunty
what's your secret well if I'm having
trouble thinking of something I guess
having cute girls never hurts cute girls
you mean like piei works I
sorry did someone just say my name god I
look so [ __ ] good today like my work
of course remember that show I helped
you with ages ago how we do a
continuation of that
but wacky one they got really popular on
Adult Swim Hey da Foley Kohli how do you
not remember fully Cooley huh screw it
I'll do it myself
you know back in my day we didn't need
to worry too much about what we were
doing all we needed was some cool
looking stuff and giant robot robot
everything would just what account is
that also how they taught you to do
endings old man no but seriously I see I
see shapes I see I see colors everywhere
he's having one of his visions again
what if we had girls except they didn't
have necks and they could tilt them it
may just cap tilting we need tilting max
how in the hell is this supposed to make
us sell anime you'd be surprised
I'll call a guy he can make this all
happen guys guys instead of arguing
about concept how about we start going
back to the basics for now that's
actually an excellent idea who the hell
are you
I'm deal media you know deal media I
mean princess jellyfish poker ahh no
Kantai collection come on you guys must
have heard of me
okay well I'm just gonna bring it over
to you you foe table oh well I think
that sorry I I gotta take this
it's just the wife hi honey how are you
whoa wait what can we talk about this
later I'm kind of in the middle of
something I'm sorry what were we talking
about again hello you beat me and Matt
blue just been chilling and having fun
something you hold folks she wouldn't
understand
he literally dragged me along I didn't
do anything
hey Matt we'll be cool right you had fun
didn't you please don't touch me wasn't
whit with you guys too
uh he got stressed about working on
attack on Titan seasons two and passed
out at the bar it's coming I promise
next year this time have you been
drinking again [ __ ] you dad you'll
control me hey you show some respect to
your elders
I taught you everything you know oh
please like you can produce anything
good nowadays in fact all you old farts
again past your prime it's time for us
young ones to take over this industry
everything any of you
all right so we're left with two options
we can all agree on either we make an
abstract over-the-top action show with
cute girls and giant robots based on
type all right I'll inform the Americans
thank you very much I'll be getting a
new anime yes but you can have this one
dear oh thanks darling I love you no no
no no I I love you more no I love you
more no no I love you I love lost I ski
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you so so much to use supplement
our key verses for doing the visuals for
this video I came to him a few months
ago with the script since I had no idea
how I was gonna do it and asked him if
he would be able to bring it to life and
I think he did an absolutely fantastic
job so I highly recommend check out some
of his work I'm also gonna leave a link
to the character models he did in the
description along with his Twitter and
if you liked this skit consider support
me on patreon but until then I've been
gig art and I'll see you all next time